Nguyên Tóc, khẩn cấp sự tán hằng chục người.
Ông lo mình đường chú tịch vui bán nhân dân sẵn đầm dài,
về với phong hệ ăn cho biết, sau khi phát hiện một phát nước trên đối,
chính quyền đã nhìn trong gì giới các khổ sần đến nơi ăn toàn,
theo từ vinh nước, sải khoảng 1 chăm mát,
sậu hay mời đến 1 mua xem cái nét, có chỗ sâu khoảng 4 nét,
được phát hiện vào khoảng 7 xe, hay mấy chiến tâm chiến,
trên đối của bèo, thuộc bản tục, sẵn đầm dàng.
Được nhất, bản tục, sẵn đầm dài có chiến mi hậu sân
với tay chậm sống người trên khổ,
chùi yếu mà người được bảo dân tục khái.
Hà phần thất khổ sân sống cách nguyễu khu vẻo khoảng 9 mét đến nằm mê.
Thì eu sức hiện với tích kiao dài, khiến người dân địa phương phố khủng lộn ăn giả hong mang.